hey gang Sam is here again to talk about
the flash season 4 premiere the flash
reborn is so excited specifically I want
to talk about everything you may have
missed because what did greg berlanti
and Andrew Kreisberg love to put in each
of the episodes of each of their TV
shows Easter eggs let's go of course
polar warning for the flash TV show
comics etc just to give a little recap
at the end of season 3 Barry sacrificed
himself to the Speed Force to stop it
from nuking the universe possibly the
multiverse it has been missing for six
months during his absence
Wally Cisco Joe and iris have become the
new team flash or team Kid Flash or team
vibe whatever
iris has really come into her own as the
team leader but it feels like he's
missing through some sciency
gobbledygook Cisco finds the perfect way
to free Barry but keep the Speed Force
intact with the help of Caitlin snow or
killer frost maybe both but oh Barry has
gone all Shia LaBeouf and transformers 2
and is now writing symbols all over the
walls and just screaming eventually
Barry is able to snap back into his old
self to save iris from the episode Big
Bad the samurai love that name and we
get some teasers for the rest of the
season but I don't want to get ahead of
myself making it all could I get a
number 10 please thank you so much and
we're gonna go ahead and start with the
beginning of the episode and work our
way to the end don't worry numbers 3 2 &
1 on this list are pretty dang juicy
alright number 10 the big Easter egg
rebirth it's the main theme of season
for at least the premiere you probably
did not miss the numerous times people
mainly Barry literally said reborn this
show was criticized for being too dark
so the show owners plan to fix it not
just by making Barry smile more no we're
talking about a whole new opening logo
new lightning transition new desks at
STAR Labs new conditioner Francisco
looks great a new suit for Barry oh my
goodness the list goes on and on and on
we even get a new role for iris as the
team leader love iris as the team leader
by the way it gives her something to do
actually harkens back to her pre new 52
in the comics when she's raising Bart
and helping Wally out it's just magical
I did like the use of the born-again
Christians storyline and having faith
even though it led to a confusing final
scene where iris is letting yourself
kidnap not here to criticize of his hunt
ray anyways moving to number 9 on the
list the samurai Android or better named
Sam Roy right sounds like hammer Roy
anyways the samurai ride has been teased
for a few months but quick backstory for
the character answer-there history they
were originally created by a character
named Barry
Kitana great name but then we got rekt
conned and then he was originally
created by T omorrow most recently
though tying it back to Reapers the
samurais made their first appearance
since the new 52 in the rebirth
crossover event the button there he was
taking a bunch of them down it's really
cool
also Cisco makes two very important
references the first being Kurosawa a
nod to one of the most influential
directors of all time who's responsible
for a little-known film named Seven
Samurai
pretty cool Cisco also mentions
Excalibur which you know makes sense
they're up against this really powerful
sword that doesn't pay off English not
criticizing it makes sense it's one of
the most popular swords in history and
it's been known in some stories to have
a special abilities it also brings it
back around to a reference to legends of
tomorrow we know though the legends of
actually met King Arthur in the past and
we find out in the premiere of legends
of tomorrow season 3 that Steele Earp's
isn't Steele has been assisting team
flash while Barry was away so I'm
guessing Nate started bragging a little
bit about his adventures yeah I would to
have a bug under Cisco's ear
bing-bang-boom you know a reference
moving on to number 8 the robes bar now
when Cisco hunts down Caitlin he
discovers she's now a bartender at a
seedy bar in Central City we made a few
lowlifes one in particular that I want
to come back to in just a little bit but
I believe this is our first introduction
to Rooms bar I know captain cold scene
at the bar before but I really hope that
this is the role spot in the flash
comics the Rogues meeting Captain Cold
heat wave going glider trickster etc all
hang out at one particular bar now the
name of the bar changes often so I can't
give you something specific and the
writers the episode didn't even give
this one a name which is a bit of a
bummer but I'm hoping we either see
Caitlin at this bar more often or
possibly we see that guy with the
one-eyed cool haircut planning some
nefarious criminal activities with his
whole crew maybe in that bar yeah their
hideout their base of operations I just
like to see Rory or Leonard or the whole
rogue gang you know hanging out there
together just a cool little fanboy heart
maybe we even get a remake of this scene
from Justice League Unlimited with the
trickster and flash here's the deal
buddy
tell me where those guys went and I
promise to come see you in the hospital
we'll play darts
the soft kind is moving on to number
seven on my Easter egg list Mockingbird
satellite Cisco mentions this piece of
technology during the episode and of
course every fan boy and girl is going
to look up ooh Mockingbird is in DC
Comics I know marvel's got a mockingbird
but DC keine unfortunately not gonna
find out too much information but don't
worry cuz this Easter Egg circles
background to another CW show now the
codename Mockingbird is usually
associated with the secret six the
secret six has been the name of a few
different teams but usually they're a
group of DC villains very cool
mockingbird is the name of the leader of
each team and the identity of this
person has usually been kept secret and
changes very frequently in the history
of this team it's usually been led by a
number of one-off characters who I'm not
gonna mention but most notably
Mockingbird has been revealed to be the
Riddler lex luthor manipulator of them
all Amanda Waller so I think Mockingbird
is the codename for a covert Argus
satellite that Cisco has access to
thanks to either working with Amanda
because she used to leave Argus or
working with Lyla who's currently
running Argus let his little connected
DC Multiverse we have on TV number 6
moving to Barry is back couldn't even
wait one whole episode to see Wally you
know become his own flash or anything
like that and it's kind of a bummer
being honest but hey Barry's back and I
will say what they do with Barry is
pretty cool in particular when he pops
out of the Speed Force running down the
road glowing with energy and completely
to the untrained eye this could mean
nothing but for fans of the Terminator
franchise I think this is a nod to when
anyone knows films travel through time
whenever anyone goes to the past and
Terminator franchise their clothes pop
off or they take them off I'm not really
clear when I was researching this video
either way he's naked it seems like a
terminator not number 5 let's talk about
Barry's new language when he pops out
the Speed Force he can't think straight
he can't talk straight he's just
shooting random words and phrases out of
his mouth he's writing all over the
walls
very rude cool pen though you're curious
if these phrases mean anything you're
right they kind of do the words he's
saying not the circles he mentions a few
things about the future of Barry and
iris from the comics now we don't know
if this is gonna happen the show some of
these things happen in the comics but
hey it's worth mentioning them few times
he says the stars are melting which
could refer to the crisis where Barry
disappears in the newspaper but there
are more concrete ones that are pretty
fun too it went out also some of you
gonna say that the speed were storm
could have been the Christ
I don't know this time lines are real
confusing now Barry at times seems to be
talking about a judge which ties back to
the memory we saw in season ones finale
where Barry is running through the Speed
Force and he sees himself in prison I'm
thinking this is a nod to the trial of
Barry Allen when he accidentally killed
the reverse-flash he he also mentions
diapers and smiles which i think is when
he remembers his irises kids dawn and
Dawn aka the tornado twins
that's so cute I just hope we get a
glimpse of them at some point in the
show at the very least their son Bart
aka impulsive yes I would be happy to
plan also the circular characters that
Barry uses look a lot like the
characters used by the aliens in arrival
which is a fun nod cents boiler alert
for arrival those words and characters
allowed people using them to gain a new
understanding of time allowing them to
see future events very talking about the
future I'll ride the past make sense
cool nod wink but it's worth mentioning
the this house is bitchin line that's
deciphered because I have zero idea as
to what they could possibly mean like
his other references this could be about
his future maybe it's when Barry finally
walks in to Batman's mansion he's like
or when he finally walks into the
fortress of solitude and he's like but
probably not I originally thought it
could have been an anagram but then kind
of came up with nothing these are the
words I found in the phrase net niche
his chess
sitting sit and nest which I'm not very
helpful did you guys come up with a good
theory for this let me know down below
next up number four on this list and we
have two golden references I just
couldn't skip during Cisco and Caitlin's
brainstorm session decipher Barry's
crazy new language
Cisco blurts out two fantastic
one-liners from two very important
individuals one fictional one real both
equally important two comics first up
great Caesar's ghost
is the catchphrase of the one and only
Perry White editor in chief of the Daily
Planet
from Superman lure Superman we've heard
this referenced once before over on
Supergirl but that was when Clark was on
the phone with Perry during his premiere
episode it's real cool Jaclyn's got a
good smile now the second reference
excelsior
comes from the one and the only Stan Lee
it's his catchphrase that he uses in
almost every single thing that he does
it's awesome Cisco is a walking
encyclopedia of nerdy references
so now I'm asking how do you find this
one just need confirmation that Marvel
Comics exists in this universe and then
all of our brains will explode now
moving on to number three these are the
big ones guys the big eggs during the
final scene we see the introduction of
the mechanic played by Kim Engelbrecht
we meet her putting together a new
samurai suit and talking to another
character on my list but I'll get to him
soon don't worry now the mechanic plays
a very minor role in the comics but what
we can gather from her short synopsis
online is that she builds devices for
the thinker similar to the tinkerer in
spider-man comics and in most recently
spider-man homecoming as her personality
traits there's nothing in the comics so
this show gets to have some fun I'm
excited to see what kind of threats if
you'd able to come up with one new tech
you know take on team flash I'm so
excited hopefully the giant mech suit
because it's comics everybody why not
now this moves is pretty easily into
number two which is of course you
guessed it the thinker played by
newcomer Neel Sandilands last name the
thinker aka Clifford Davao at least in
this show has been teased a sense a last
season during the abra-cadaver
introductory episode we hear Abra
mentioned the greatest flash villains
Deveaux being one of them now the
thinker's abilities usually consist of a
form of telekinesis mind-control
telepathy but most importantly
controlling technology with his brain
and integrating with it now the thinker
plays a rather big role in Geoff Johns
run when he wrote for wally west and
that's the same run that introduced
peekaboo who we saw in the beginning of
this episode now I've got a theory
Bruner and it's basically confirmed with
my final Easter egg but one last thing I
want to point out when DeVoe got into
the crime game in the comics before he
got all creepy looking he would help
criminals stay out of jail and the first
person he worked for was a mob boss with
the name of Norwalk and when you look up
the IMDB info for that creepy guy with
the eye and the haircut in the Rogues
bar his name is Norwalk as well I don't
think these characters are the same but
it's still fun point now and now to
number one my final Easter Egg is the
name ominous domina is looking to be
another big bed this season but you can
relax she's not a speedster amana is a
fairly popular rogue for wally west who
created a vast network of criminals
called
the network not creative but still cool
but eventually she makes her own team of
rogues as well we get a tease of this
network when Norville threat
katelyn when she says that she wants to
go back to her old job at STAR Labs very
intriguing threatening her when she
wants to leave I'd love to see a big
team of villains led by ammonite go up
against the flash now wouldn't you as
for ominous background there's not much
known she also goes by the name
blacksmith and she has the ability to
manipulate metal and fuse it to her
flesh as like an armor she's also an
expert strategist which makes sense
because she makes this vast network I'm
in its biggest flash moment though comes
from the same Geoff Johns run with the
flash with the tinkerer and peekaboo
Amna and the thinker take over the Twin
Cities Keystone and central city and
Wally West has to take out both threats
simultaneously it's pretty freakin sweet
and I can't wait to see how they plan to
adapt these characters and the storyline
in the show hey guys really quick just
so fun here some honorable mentions we
see Picabo at the very beginning I
mentioned that before she's the
teleporting rogue from Season one who's
been missing since season runs so it's
cool to see her back again cisco
mentions danville and the flatlands as
parts of central city which are both
areas of central city in the comics so
the winged Cisco is caught saying see
you tomorrow boss which is literally the
same line the car uses to Leena Luther
in the premiere of Supergirl season 3
very cool and finally this might not be
the newest thing but I've never done one
of these videos here so I want to point
it out killer frost is making her killer
mr. freeze jokes you won't like me when
I'm frosty yeah we all cringe but you
know you kind of love it because her
character makes no sense why would a
person gain a personality when she gains
abilities no one else did is it a
psychotic break because if it is I'm not
treating it like that I knew that's it
for me what did you guys think of my
eggs and my theories did I miss anything
let me know down below and hit me up on
twitter at sam basher but before you do
that check out all of our other
breakdowns on this channel and give this
video a like again I'm Sam basher and
I'll see you next time